welcome in this video you will learn how
to create a simple multiband compressor
with the included devices in bit Weg
Studio my name is Matias and this is
morning do media let's
go before we start the multic
compression design I think we need some
audio to work with so let's uh record a
little acoustic guitar take with the
seal acoustic guitar and then we will
create the multiband compressor
[Music]
okay so what kind of devices do we need
for a multiband compressor well let's
open up the device browser or bitwig and
uh we only want to view the bitwig
devices then we go to audio effects and
then you can see we have the multiband
Effect 2 and the multiband effects 3 and
what these devices do is that they split
up the audio uh the frequency spectrum
of the audio in three different areas so
you have the base area and you have the
mid-range area and you have the highs
and you can see that here in this device
the low the mid and the highs in the
regular compressor you're compressing
the overall frequency spectrum but with
this multiband compressor you're uh
compressing the different areas
differently if you want and then with
this multiband effect we can go into
each of these uh device slots within
this device and we can go and add the
Dynamics processor from bitwig
you could use the compressor but uh if
you look at the attack time of the
compressor it only goes down to2 and the
release only goes down
to 38
milliseconds but uh generally with
the with a multiband compressor you want
the faster attacks and faster releases
so if we then take the Dynamics we can
see that the Dynamics goes down to with
an attack of 0.1
milliseconds and a release to 10
milliseconds so now we have this
Dynamics processor inserted in the base
area of our frequency
spectrum and then we can play with the
ratio maybe set it to
point4 and just let's play back the
audio and see
what what
happens we can set a attack slightly up
to
maybe let's set it to something around
millisecs and the release around 10
milliseconds
13 in the Spectrum window we can see how
much compression we are doing to the
signal and currently you can see that
the audio the audio level is not
reaching our threshold so let's reduce
that so we start uh to get some
[Music]
compression maybe a little bit
more a little bit lower threshold and
now in order to control this separately
because if we look at the multiband
effect it has a
mix mix level adjuster but that will
adjust the overall mix for all these
three different slots but uh with this
type of multiband compression I think it
would be cool if we add if we add
separate mix controls for each of the
Bands so let's add this Shane device so
now we have a separate mix for this base
[Music]
compressor and now when this uh this
part is created we can actually just
select the Shan device in this low slot
and then hold in alt and drag this to
the mid slot and also drag it to the
high slot and now we have three
different compressors for each of the
bands in in the frequency spectrum then
let's go to the mid open up the Shain
and look at if it's affecting the signal
maybe drag down the threshold
slightly decrease the ratio slightly
also
decrease the attack to maybe go around 8
milliseconds 6 to 8
milliseconds these attack and release
times it really depends on the material
that you have but it's very good to
experiment and see what kind of result
you
get so there we have some compression
going
on and uh go into our
he and for the heist we will decrease
the attack and release even
more you can see since the the acoustic
guitar sound is more centered in the
lower mids and the
lows we have a lot less uh compression
going on on the upper range so we can
decrease the threshold slightly for that
one
too yeah so now we have our multiband
compressor set up but uh we want some
controls some easy access to controls to
be able to control thresholds for the
different areas of the spectrum
field so what we do we go into the
wrench icon within the multiband effect
and then we create the preset page
within within this uh remote controls
editor so just press the plus sign there
and add this
performance now we can press the learn
button
for any of these
slots press the learn button and expand
your lower view to begin with and press
the
mix this mix knob of the Shain do the
same thing for the next a go to the mids
and learn the mix knob for the mids
excuse me then go to the third and do
the same thing with the
highs then below here we will do the
same thing the learn button go to the
lows and select the
threshold do the same thing for the mids
select the
threshold and then for the highs press
the highs and learn the
threshold and then we have to rename
this because they say mix mix mix and it
should actually read low
mix mid
mix and high
mix and same thing here low
threshold this is the mid
threshold and this is the high high
threshold so now we have three different
mix level
controls and then of course we also have
this uh the mix for the whole compressor
[Music]
[Laughter]
and actually I will add a EQ before this
multiband compressor because
uh this wasn't the most uh perfect room
to record in but um we can get rid of
some of the lows some of the absolute
lows before we go with the audio into
the multiband
effect like that
[Music]
so with this multiband compressor we can
do some really creative stuff with our
recording take so let's boost the the
highs a little
bit to get a little bit more crisp out
of this guitar sound maybe reduce the
lows slightly increase increase the mids
slightly and then we can choose how much
we want to blend this multiband
compression into the original
audio Maybe have the lows really
controlled with this multiband
compressor and the mids and up range a
little bit
more slightly
[Music]
processed so you get a much more
controlled sound with a multiband
compressor and then let's uh finish this
sound up by adding some a little bit of
blur we can actually use this
uh blur dabler
preset to get the guitar a little bit
more stereo then add some
Reverb or yeah let's use the Bala room
Reverb instead
[Music]
yeah so that's how simple it is to
create a multiband compressor within bit
week studio if you have any questions on
music production sound design or using
any of the devices in bitwig studio
please shoot me them in the comments
below okay so what do you think about
this multiband compression setup in
bitwig studio I think it's a really
solid setup and you get access to all
these different controls of every
compressor for each band of the spectrum
field it's not Ott by any means but hey
Ott is free so go and download it at
xfer if you if you prefer to use Ott my
future based single Ghan fly is finally
out on the streaming platforms like
Spotify iTunes and Amazon so go and
check that one out okay so that's all
for today and now you can continue and
watch my next video thanks to all the
new subscribers we just hit the 2K Mark
really lovely thank you so much for
joining this musical
Journey thanks for today and see you in
the next video bye
[Music]
[Applause]